[Music]
what's the scandal your school was known
for
this was on twitter
security guard had a security guard had
a fully functional meth lab in our
chemistry class it was closed down for
months after that nah surely not
the security guard to be fair if you're
the security guard at school you can
and you've got nothing in your account
yeah facts
security got a score
yeah a security guard at the school
you're not getting paid yeah yeah that
method i'll be doing up meth labs as
well yeah water white in the whole thing
yeah rags
the principal was running a dogfight
ring in the middle of the night on
weekends out of the gymnasium
teachers were involved and even some
students
only reason they got caught is because a
teacher's only fans of couch showed the
dogs fighting while she was giving head
to someone no that's not true
that's not true bro
just not in the background some dog dogs
and you just see the principal in there
prince won a couple students students
and you say no no no no you see like an
emblem that's my school big man
they got caught hang on
that twisted
they got caught because one of the
teachers has an only fans and she was
sucking dick
in the fight ring
in the fight arena or the area yeah
and saw a couple dogs in her back
also yeah
dogs principals and students in the back
yeah
also
who was watching the oni fans video
who's the snitch yeah that was signed up
to our only fans that's what i want to
know who's the [ __ ] snitch that was
on only fans probably the person
the whole thing dog fighting the whole
thing
mad man's closed a lot of doors for a
lot of people all right there was money
being made that day yeah oh from all
different angles there was money being
made that day mad he's [ __ ] up so many
bases
my school janitor was selling student
semen at a sperm
bank for what
for what
who was buying it
what do they need semen for [ __ ] nose
[ __ ] knows jesus
xccsu athlete says he had to drink blood
no new britain um a former
a former writer at the
central connecticut state university has
sued the school saying a coach forced
him to drink blood as a kind of tribal
ritual and these men have lost their
mind a tribal ritual i'm not drinking
anyone's blood
a third grader at my sister's elementary
school dressed up as hitler
did a presentation on him
and had her report hung up in the
hallway for a month
the assignment was about world leaders
who had great achievements 50 of the
school students were jewish
mad hitler was a great world leader
he achieved a lot to be fair he did
achieve
a lot he's not greatness but there's not
greatness it's impressive
i'm just i'm just going to throw it out
there controversial
it's impressive the genghis khan needed
bits too he had everyone on the road
one country
had
europe on the ropes
the world war was literally the world
versus germany germany versus him yeah
impressive mad
this is just a heading former teacher
and coach arrested again for touching
students nah
again
again james
former bloomingdale high school teacher
sentenced to 15 years for voyeurism
involving over a hundred students for
what voyeurism what's that when you
watch people
when someone's a voice it means no when
when someone's a voyager they either
like watching or like being watched
during sex oh cuckid yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like that you like being watched or
you like watching so who is he watching
hundreds i have 100 students he was
watching students or students watching
him
either way
either way penitentiary
i don't even know if it's a scandal but
some kid had a kill list in his locker
even brought the strap to school he just
didn't end up doing it [ __ ] had
me second in line
oh on the list
oh my god i'm leaving at school today
immediately today
and i'm so offended
why i'd have to confront him like why
why am i second what did i do why am i
even on the list what did i actually do
[ __ ] had me second on the line
no way
my i would fall to my knees bro
i'll be like i could have not made it
home today you know when they
when they post the like who made the
cheerleading squad yeah everyone gathers
around when we find this kill list
everyone gathers around i'm at the back
i'm seeing man looking at me
what's everyone look at that bro [ __ ]
you looking at and just see
the school bastard number top and then
me
i'm like my world would collapse bro
because everyone's onto you like what
did you do tomorrow what did you do
especially if i'm looking at man and
they're like make sense
makes sense [ __ ] off
our band director was caught with male
prostitutes in his hotel while we was on
a school trip
fam
this one sweetie
one time the cook made nothing but
potatoes for dinner
bro that would start a riot in my family
that was
no no sausages
no chickens
phone calls
yeah yeah no tuck shop nothing
no tuck shop just potatoes
now fun that's a scandal i don't think
you get it
that's one of the funniest things i've
ever read
oh my god explain yourself that's what i
have to
tell me something bro
what do you mean they're [ __ ] having
potatoes today that's what's happening
nah
that's too funny oh that's jokes the
treasure of the school
sorry the treasure of the school got
caught stealing bands of money oh this
is this is multiple sorry the treasure
of the school got caught stealing bands
of money one a special ed girl got a
special ed boy
a special ed girl got pregnant by a
special ed boy number two wow number
three
two teachers got caught by a special ed
kid having sex in the classroom i got
fired
is this a special ed school
mad
it's whatever that you know that you
would tell everyone ram
if i'm one of those teachers getting
clocked by a special ed's
student
i'm spinning lies yeah he's uh he's a
fault he's a [ __ ] little liar don't
believe a word that comes like this
about did you use mouth bro
don't believe a word why but when you
said that as well i was thinking i feel
like if i was a teacher in the school
yeah i'd be [ __ ] the female teachers
in the school okay or inside the school
or from the school inside the school
okay i don't know why because this is
such a boring job yeah and i've got
nothing to do you're you're always
flirting in there like your teacher's
life
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're only similar
to your restaurant stories yeah you're
always flirting relax bro is this
banging teachers because you're there
literally every day every single day
yeah yeah same with every other job but
like it's it's so ancestral and there's
skirts up in here
there's skirts up in here of age by the
way we're talking about people
yeah yeah there's there's there's just
things yeah
yeah bro everything everyone's bored
[Music]
yeah
i'd consistently be banging
i'd get caught oh rags rags
gay sex in a wood shop bathroom recorded
and distributed to the entire school
from a teacher
potentially potentially wow
freshmen stole vandalized and destroyed
the bathrooms to the point of it being
of them being closed off a whole sink
was ripped off the wall
everybody had to use a portable bar from
in front of the school for a year and a
half a year and a half is how long it
takes to fix some bathrooms i'm leaving
the school what did they do i'm leaving
the school rags but yes my mum wouldn't
let me continue with this school but
yeah those are the those are the
scandals
scandals of the week the school scandals
of the week that's insane bro some of
them things were there was one i read
that i can't find now obviously
something with peter like p-e-t-a the
animated people it said
um
students dissected um cat intestines or
playing jump rope with it
no
brother i saw the thing
not a video but like a screenshot of a
news thing
fam you know wasn't mad
i'm always such an advocate of like when
people are like oh you're influencing
like like tick tock stuff or whatever
and they're like these apps are
dangerous they're influencing kids and
i'm always on the side oh shut up
shut up
like
let the kids do what they want to do
they're not
start [ __ ] killing people chill it's
all good yeah and then you hear that
yeah and i think i don't think anything
but tick-tock you need someone to take
out cat intestines and start skipping
right now that has to be tick-tock i
don't know
because no one else has the power to
yeah yeah
for power because my bedroom couldn't
convince me yeah never no one could
never only a famous person could
convince me to do it
only literally only the youtuber of
youtubers at the tangerine fourteenth
impressionable age could convince me to
start slaughtering cats and skipping
around with their intestines no one else
could convince me with that that's no
one else has that level of influence
over me especially
if there's multiple of us
because no there's not a ringleader all
of us do that
it has to be a trend
[Music]